say hi and bye all right hello
say bye are you even working from home
if you're video chat isn't crashed by
your kid well that's just what happened
to Travis Scott with the hamburger see
hi hi oh no slide the 27 year old rapper
went on Instagram live this week to
preview new music video chatting with
Kid Cudi and even drinking tequila a
monist killer when his two-year-old
daughter stormy with his ex Kylie Jenner
came in looking for her daddy you see
daddy gonna play I don't want it
I mean my heart you know stormy about -
um I don't know do something I'll be
back with a hoe what you do you said
what no you don't want to what okay
can't watch this movie I'll be bad guy
to put on a movie see you later stars
they're just like us guys I'm hiding in
the guest room because my kids
Kylie's big sis Kim Kardashian who's
quarantined with her hubby Kanye West
and their four kids
amid the corona virus pandemic
straight-up hid in the guest room to try
and film a makeup tutorial Lauren can I
please just do my little tutorial come
on
the answer is no guys it's all I want to
do is one little fun thing for myself
oh then there was this hi every
in California it's Kim kardashian-west
and I just wanted to talk to you analyze
West have a serious conversation with
you guys about social distancing I know
it's California we've got the most
beautiful weather but we have to start
to train ourselves you went outside in
your backyard and that's totally fine
Kim filmed a PSA encouraging fans to
stay at home but her six-year-old
daughter North crashed the whole damn
thing I know that can you not jump on
the bed give me like two seconds to
seriously do this it's the comedy we all
need right now see hi but back to stormy
Kylie shared this clip to Instagram
that's the tiny tot looking Quarantine
fab in a pair of bedazzled shades and a
food stained t-shirt store me your
t-shirt what did you do for dinner time
you went crazy is that popcorn in my
hair same girl same I'm having fun Kylie
and Travis have been spending a lot of
time together with stormy during
quarantine taking a dip in the pool
they even spent Easter as a family in
Palm Springs I have bought her every
single outdoor toy could imagine she has
bouncy houses out there water toys she's
been in the pool every day she's been
outside every day and during an insta
Live
Kylie shared the activities they're
doing for fun I'm trying to keep her
entertained a baby and like didn't
realize what that there's no idea what's
going on no everything when et caught up
with Kylie's dad Caitlyn Jenner in March
she opened up about how Kylie was coping
with quarantine I think Kylie's happy
because she's at home and spending a lot
of time with stormy and she loves that
Kylie is a homebody
Kendall likes getting out but she loves
being at home she loves cooking loves
being you know a little stormy
and she's doing just fine
[Music]